hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter Bonet dziak and today is the very
first edition of our vs. series get
excited and the vs. series we take two
of our panelists with opposing views and
have them fight out specific topics
right here on the show
today's topic Batgirl versus Robin who
is the more valuable member of the back
the bat family we'll get into specifics
about that in one moment but first I
want to thank you guys for the response
to the Snyder ring yeah that's some
getting a lot of really good attention
for us if you want more Snyder ring make
sure you comment ask for more Snyder and
use the hashtag the Snyder ring on
Twitter or whatever just keep get that
thing going because if you guys want
more demand it and we'll give you more
because there's plenty of different
avenues we can go with a character and
everything so keep commenting about that
also make sure to like our new Facebook
page at facebook.com slash awesome
comics show pores review of arrow season
4 is still up on there if you want to
check that out that's exclusive to the
Facebook page also there's always
exclusive pictures reviews etc that are
going up on that page so like it right
now as always I want to thank you guys
for commenting about what you want to
see us cover on the show always ask and
we will do our best to cover what you
guys want to see ok so now that's out a
way let's go into intros we'll go with
you first you are a girl I could tell
what is your name though interesting
intro Ayane is my name I think you guys
know it I don't know what happened to my
cohort here but yes ayan Wade
okay that's the first time I've heard
that I've never seen I'm a guy you're uh
oh I'm a guy oh okay go ahead Oh Brian
Porter I am his friend and yeah
hopefully he remembers Who I am
I remember I just you know had my wisdom
teeth removed a couple days ago I don't
really know where I'm at right now but
we're gonna keep going with this it's
awesome timing right that that's it
that's it awesome comics okay so what
we're gonna do now is give a little bit
of a character history about Batgirl
Barbara Gordon and the Tim Drake version
of Robin we're gonna go with Ayanna's
Barbara Gordon
girl first take it away I own the bat
girl bat - girl character was first
introduced as Betty King niece of bat
woman Kathy King in 1961 some people
believe that the lady bats were
introduced as romantic interests to
debunk the long-standing theory of
Batman's homosexuality a mere six years
later Barbara Gordon was introduced in
Detective Comics number 359 the million
dollar debut of that girl and later that
year in the third season of the Batman
TV show played by Yvonne Craig she was
accepted by fans as a welcome addition
to the dynamic duo and during the Silver
Age she worked alongside Batman and
Robin Superman and Supergirl and
occasionally the Justice League until
crisis of deepening Earth's the modern
age daughter of Jim Gordon had a pivotal
moment in 1988 The Killing Joke where
she was shot by the Joker hitting her
spine and paralyzing her from the waist
down not one to leave crime-fighting
that easily she transformed herself into
Oracle who still helped Aztec scientists
liaison for the JLA and a big sister to
the bat family birds of prey and future
bat girls very interesting information
looks like you're really excited to get
into this Porter Tim Drake Robin take it
away Timothy Jackson Drake Wayne created
by Marv Wolfman and Pat Broderick first
appeared as Tim Drake in Batman number
436 in August of 1989 and as Robin in
Batman number 442 December 1989 seeing
Nightwing do a quadruple flip that he
saw years earlier performed by Dick
Grayson of the circus he deduced
Nightwing's identity and later Batman's
as Bruce Wayne seeing how reckless and
brutal Batman has become after the death
of Robin Jason Todd he implores Batman
to take him under his wing and train him
to be the new Robin in hopes of keeping
Batman in check after extensive training
Batman accepts him as the new Rob
after the events of battle for the cowl
Tim takes the identity of Red Robin and
later Batman Beyond
after futures end all right we have a
little bit of a the ground set for this
battle here before we get underway so
you guys know a little bit about Tim
Drake a little bit about Barbara Gordon
now and we're gonna jump into this right
now okay first topic who was the better
combatant who is the better fighter
the barber Gert bought the Barbara
Gordon vision of that girl's barber
Gorger or the Tim Drake version of Robin
let's start with you first Porter I'm
it's definitely Tim Drake Robin he he
when he first came on to train with
Batman he trained under Batman and then
he went all over the world training with
various masters in all types of fighting
jujitsu ninjutsu and stuff like that he
he is actually considered the best
combatant with a staff in the entire
world his bow staff skills are insane
I'd like to see him take on Donnie from
Ninja Turtle Oh that'd be a good and
well that's silence I'm an just I can't
with the nevermind he is insanely he's
very acrobatic he's like take take Jason
Todd and Tim gerrera
stick grace Dick Grayson and put them
together as far as their combat and
fighting skills you know with the
acrobatics of Dick Grayson the brutality
of Jason Todd and you you put that into
Tim Drake and you've got this awesome
guy who's very comparable to Batman
himself okay and I think that he is a
top-notch fighter and but one of the
cool things about him is he doesn't
always resort to fighting he actually
likes to assess the situation before he
even gets into it he doesn't he doesn't
instantly jump into the fray he is very
analytical in his fighting style and I
think that really helps him and be a
very formidable opponent so I think he's
awesome in that respect okay Batgirl um
well in the original TV show Yvonne has
talks about her choreography as being
more show girly than like martial arts
but in the modern era we know that she
studied judo and karate and she's
attributed with the
a martial arts expert and a star athlete
in the new 52 version they talk about
her having self-defense classes and she
was six and possibly Escrima on in the
first trade of the Batgirl the Stewart
and Fletcher version she has a bit of a
scrimmage with Black Canary too for for
training purposes and she uses bo staffs
and we know that as Oracle she does use
Escrima sticks and she keeps them
actually in the armrest of her
wheelchair so which by the way it's the
martial arts from the Philippines it's
actually their national sport and it's
weapons based combat and it also uses
like hands hand and like weapons
disarming and stuff if you weren't sure
what that was but she also there's
another panel in here where she's a
black belt in karate and she looks
pretty small and she also takes ballet
so should we know that she's acrobatic
we know that she has martial arts
training and we know that she is in
general a very star athlete so she's
very physically capable in robbing
wanted I know that Batman says that he
could never beat Batgirl technically
he's talking about Cassandra Cain but
maybe with the transitive property but I
am saying that for sure Barbara Gordon
is definitely a force to be reckoned
with as Batgirl and definitely as Oracle
even in the combat even with being a
paraplegic yeah but one thing about Tim
Drake in the new 52 he's actually an
Olympian he's or he's going to be an
Olympian an Olympic athlete and so if
you take your Olympic athlete skills and
then you train in various forms of
martial arts how much of a force to be
reckoned with are you going to be like
that's insane he actually his favorite
is Bhoja 2 which is taught in ninjutsu
and he's spot against ant spawn sparred
again
and beaten Lady Shiva Oh like seriously
he's a beast
you get them a staff any staff dunzo
okay all right well these guys are
definitely I mean it sounds like if
they're part of the bat family they're
obviously gonna have a lot of training
and I'm glad you guys knew the specifics
on that okay
moving on to the next topic here who is
smarter I mean we've heard a lot about
Tim Drake being very intelligent in the
same way with Barbara Gordon why don't
you start off Ayanna how smart is
Batgirl well most people when they think
of Barbara Gordon Batgirl they think of
her intelligence before they would think
of her combat
I would definitely argue that she is
smarter she's a genius-level intellect
in any version even in the original
Batman television series and she's
always been like tech oriented a
computer expert she in general is a very
of like an incredibly developed female
comic book character because of her
smarts in the Silver Age she has a
doctoral degree and her career as a
librarian and then later ends up working
for the US Congress in the new 52 she's
younger much younger she's more of a
recent graduate and she has I believe
her degrees in forensic psychology
specifically and we know that she has a
photographic memory which comes up a lot
in the in the in the Fletcher version
yeah and as Oracle obviously we know
that she's highly intelligent because as
a member of the JLA prometheus actually
targets her at one point because he says
he believes that she is the most
powerful member because of her
intelligence and because of her
knowledge of what's going on and
everything so when she is paralyzed she
has to kind of rely more on her
intellect yeah and I think in Oracle
specifically it really shows just how
smart she is but she's always had that
that brain going on up there yeah
okay let's hear a little bit about Tim
Drake's intelligence also a genius-level
intellect Tim Drake is so smart at nine
years old he saw Robin and Batman or
Dick Grayson at the Terre not Nightwing
at the time he saw him execute a
quadruple flip okay and he saw the same
exact flip years previously when he saw
the flying Grayson's the night that they
were actually killed he was at that
circus and he met Dick Grayson before
the show and that actually was their
first meeting and all that stuff but he
saw a Dick Grayson pull off a quadruple
flip at that time and then he saw it
again later on as Nightwing and he's
like holy crap that's Dick Grayson and
then he was able to deduce that Dick
Grayson who's Bruce Wayne's ward he
deduced that Batman is Bruce Wayne or
Bruce Wayne is Batman at nine years old
nine years old he did that Marv it's
pretty smart well he's a detective but
Barbara Gordon's also the daughter of a
detective and wants to become a
detective herself so they both have
detective property well if you want to
talk about the detective yeah after a
huge battle with Rachael ghoul and
eventually defeating him and getting the
best of ratio head of the demon race
looks at him and said and calls him
detective something he only ever called
Batman okay I'm just gonna grab it Mike
on that drop right there pen is mightier
the pen is mightier and Rachele ghoul
calling Tim Drake a Robin Detective
which is something you only did for
Batman come on how smart how smart do
you have to be well Batman even says at
some point I don't remember what issue
but he says like he'll surpass him and
detective thank you
I mean it's it happened bring it up I
mean I'm just detecting though not
necessarily in intelligence because
that's a photographic memory so she
remembers okay let's go in the terms of
his you know regular memory he still is
exactly regular memory his standard
memory memory he's still way up there
with the likes of Batman and Batgirl
you know I'm just saying scoffed at
background I'm just saying he is super
and actually with his intelligence he's
been able to deduce the identities of
other superheroes like the flash other
super girls in trust Barbara Gordon with
their identities and others knows like
hey I'm I'm this person
Tim's like Clark Kent take off put the
glasses on Supes
he's the only person who could see that
I'm just the flesh Barry Allen he
deduced that how are you gonna do step
when the flash is flying by you can't
even see his ass he's so smart
he doesn't need photographic memory he
apparently has super vision to stop him
get a little faith right there
apparently he does not have super vision
that's not yeah let's clarify someone's
gonna be like actually right but I mean
how do you are you gonna do the flash
come on that's pretty that's pretty epic
any other big you know smart level
intellect things you want to say about
Tim Drake basically he's a wiz and
computer science his technological tech
skills his tech skills are insane his uh
his little layer that he has is so
technologically fortified and awesome
that it rivals the batcaves
systems it's awesome it's awesome the
only one that has ever been able to
really kind of get into that was I think
her name is Harper she's in the new 52
right now she's a pretty cool character
but his tech skills are insanely good
he's also an expert in biology and some
various other skill OHS science skills
and all that okay she's super smart
all right smart both of these characters
are very smart all right rely on your
photographic memory with his you know
regular memory he's still whoop stands
Mary yeah last thing here we got to do
this quickly who is the more well-known
or iconic character and
Ayana why is it a Barbara Gordon Batgirl
more iconic than Tim Drake's Robin I
mean right away when you think back girl
who do you think it's Barbara Gordon
which necessarily I don't think you
think you know Tim Drake when you think
Robin but that's specifically like for
back earlier you think okay Barbara
Gordon although there are other
interpretations and more recent ones as
well
in 2011 IGN ranked the top 100 comic
book heroes Barbara Gordon was number 17
Tim Drake 32 by the way when was that
what year 2011 right um 17th and she's
also been really important in a lot of
social issues people talk about her when
they like librarian issues a lot of
people think that it was kind of a
throwaway job in the original Batman
series but I think a lot more people
nowadays realize that it was a
respectful career and she's also been
used to promote literacy Jean ha he did
a campaign that was librarians are
heroes every day which is a really cool
picture and campaign that he helped out
with and and yeah so like as the
alter-ego of Batgirl she is a librarian
so a lot of people think of that as just
her day job whereas the Oracle really
uses it as like her encyclopedia a trick
like knowledge and uses it to its full
potential
she's also used to talk about characters
with disabilities as Oracle she isn't
crippled as part of her origin it's
something she has to actually adapt to
after being so physically active like
her whole life and yet she proves that
becoming handicapped does not end your
career and then of course being a part
of the liberation movement when she was
first introduced as a character and even
now we talk about how women are treated
in comics
because of her and specifically The
Killing Joke and how writing tends to
treat women characters more brutally for
instance Batman breaks his back during a
fight with bane and he heals and
recovers fine
whereas barbara gordon gets ambushed by
the Joker and is crippled for years so
it's a lot of her has been used to talk
about the way we treat comic book
characters and stuff like that so iconic
wise that's that okay Tim Drake iconic
well ok you might have me in some of the
more actual real world issues but Tim
Drake is the first Robin to come in
under the Robin mantle not under tragedy
but for altruistic reasons he came in he
told Batman he's like you're reckless
you're brutal you're you're not taking
care of yourself you need that Robin you
need that check and I'm gonna do that
for you
and he came in to help Batman I think
that he's gonna be known as the Robin
who came in for good just because he
wanted to help because he he saw
something and he's like I can do that I
can be a service to the people and I'm
gonna help Batman and make sure he
doesn't kill himself or cross that line
which he so often flirts with and he
said he's going to be there for him and
I think that is a big part of his
character and that's why a lot of people
are going to know Tim Drake as one of
the better Robins because he was there
for Batman when he needed him and then
you also have Red Robin he is Red Robin
and that is a very iconic character that
is the only he's also the only character
Robin to have his own Robin series for
years and that is a big part of the
Robin
you know mythos or whatever you would
like to say yeah he's the only one I
mean that is be king of own Robin series
fun fact
Batgirl didn't have her own title series
until like the new millennia she was
always in Detective Comics Suicide Squad
you know she was starring in other
people's stuff but she didn't actually
have her own title comic until like the
new newer version which happened to
because
not Barbara Gordon but they've redone
that and now it's Barbara it's the
current Batgirl is Barbara Gordon
but yeah speaking of standalone comics
yeah kind of kind of weird definitely
right she's been out since the 60s what
why did it take so long that's crazy
good Claude he's also not only Red Robin
he's also been affiliated in lead Teen
Titans and Young Justice sure so he's
he's been throughout I think more of the
DC Universe and in teams and such like
that so when you think of you know Teen
Titans you think of Young Justice you're
gonna think of Red Robin when you think
of you know basically like new 52 and
like Red Robin helping out and then
futures end he was a big part in futures
and so now he's actually was actually
Batman Beyond and Tim Drake is Batman
Beyond in the future so that's a big
part for Tim Drake I mean I know he's
not Robin there but that's a big thing
for Tim Drake he's Batman Beyond and
that is awesome title to have that's all
I think that he's he's still pretty
well-known in those respects okay well
that was a great debate from you guys I
really liked hearing about the different
aspects of these characters and your
take on them was really funny here so I
want to ask you guys who do you think
won this debate is it Ayanna's Batgirl
or is it Porter's Tim Drake Robin go
ahead and comment could you go ahead and
use Team Batgirl or team Robin in the
comments who is your favorite character
I don't know what's going on who is your
favorite character do you like
personally do you like Tim Drake better
do you like Barbara Gordon or do you
like another man and sidekick I would
love to hear obviously there's other
Robins obviously there's other batgirls
we would love as we all is a great
character
yeah so go ahead and comment about who
you think won that debate and who is
your favorite all right we're gonna go
very quickly into the Pick of the Week
Ayanna you've got a ton of them here
which one are you picking I'm gonna make
it worse as specific back earlier one is
an incredible series so you should
definitely check it out if you haven't
before but I specifically really like
number 7 there's some really good a lot
of it follows her having to fight off a
lot of different villains but
specifically this one it's a lot of
seeing her and not so much the villains
in the series which is kind of nice and
we get to see some really cool combat
stuff with her and the Black Canary and
we have green arrows in this one I
really like when she gets facial burns
and has to put a mud mask over her face
to make sure that her dad doesn't figure
out that she's Batgirl because she has
like cowl singed into her face I really
like that image in this issue that's one
one of my favorite panels yeah go go
check out this whole series but this
issue is my favorite okay so next week
guys we're gonna be doing something
different again and we're gonna be
playing the game injustice and arguing
about some different kind of topics I
think you guys will want to check out um
so go ahead and come back for that next
week so social media for everybody
Ayanna where can we find you Twitter
Instagram Facebook you know thank you
you know okay border facebook.com slash
awesome Porter all right Porter Porter's
on the Fox book everybody Fox the Fox
you can find me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and as always go ahead
and like the Facebook page for awesome
comics facebook.com slash awesome comics
shoe while you're at it you can just
like this video too if you want to see
more specific talks with the vs. if you
what do you want to see this part about
what characters you want to see is there
any like topics like which actors you
think played a certain role bed
ask us and move look we love fighting
each other so we do it off cameras that
we would love to do it on camera
absolutely
so okay all right everybody until next
time I'm Walter Bernays yak for these
guys they're fantastic and until next
week we'll see you on the next page
Oh